if you went on to Facebook in the hours
after Boris Johnson was named Britain's
new prime minister you might have
noticed an ad like this or perhaps it
was one like this what you won't have
realized is that you are being targeted
and tested as part of a giant experiment
on British voters as soon as Boris
Johnson was selected more than 500
similar ads flooded onto Facebook often
showing identical versions of the same
thing with just a few tiny variations
like these ads everything's the same
except for the colors this one's red
probably for labour voters and this one
is blue not just any blue but the exact
turquoise blue of the brexit party the
ants sending to a website with a survey
asking what's the most important issue
for you and your family right now which
asks for your name postcode and email
click Submit on that nice red button and
you give the Conservatives the rights to
use your data for marketing which comes
in very handy for you guessed it
Facebook Ads the reason for running lots
of variations of ads is because you're
trying to essentially in one side's
trying to find which one's work so
you'll have tiny variants to see you
know maybe you'll find a few percent
difference in how those ads are
performing but equally it might be that
those ads are being targeted in
different audiences they might be using
different channels so obviously Facebook
displays through its ad archive all of
the ads that are running at a moment
they might be running on Instagram or
they might be running on mobile Facebook
they might be running on facebook.com so
who are the moments behind this campaign
one key figure is done when it comings
the Prime Minister's newly appointed
senior advisor that's him at Downing
Street last night wearing a t-shirt for
a Silicon Valley startup that makes
friendly AI it's this preparation for an
election who knows although it does have
that air and one thing's for sure it
raised some comfortable questions about
democratic free choice this campaign is
micro targeting the exact technique we
saw mark zuckerberg hauled before the US
Senate thanks to its de plummet by
Cambridge analytical a firm repeatedly
linked to vote leave you might say well
all the parties about it and that's
plainly true but it doesn't mean it's
good for our democratic institutions
Paul
always used to get accused of being
two-faced now 500 faces is probably more
accurate